Charlie Lynch a medical marijuana
dispensary owner from Morro Bay
California Owen Beck a high school
athlete than a cancer patient then a
client at lynches dispensary than the
raid a raid by armed federal agents
local medical marijuana users will have
to go elsewhere for the time being after
federal agents and sheriff's deputies
shut off their supply now Charlie Lynch
is in the midst of a federal trial where
he could face more than 100 years behind
bars it's hard to imagine you know that
they they would want to do that to me
this is my mom Bodine and my sister
Amanda they came all the way from New
Mexico to be with me here during the
trial
my mom's gonna be heading back to New
Mexico this evening my youngest son pet
is having major surgery tomorrow he's
been diagnosed with colon cancer well
Charlie Lynch's mom was preparing to
leave Owen Beck was preparing to take
the stand we met with him in his hotel
room at the end of the day I walked in
there everyone was really quiet I looked
over at charlie he seemed kind of kind
of scared sitting there with this with
his attorneys and i really knew that
that these people would have to get him
they asked me how old I was where I
worked where I went to school and then
basically I was asked how I don't Lynch
Charlotte Lynch in prison as a person
and then I proceeded to let them know
that I was i did have bone cancer two
years ago and I was prescribed medical
marijuana for my oncologist at Stanford
and then after I began my second
sentence the judge actually cut me off
and dismissed the jury those were the
last words Owen Beck will be allowed to
speak in the trial of Charlie Lynch I
don't think it was fair to Charlie in
any way I think they should have at
least heard my testimony and heard you
know that charlie is a law-abiding
person I would trust my medical people
that take care of my medical needs to my
oncologist at Stanford University more
than the DEA without the use of Charlie
winches dispensary during my
chemotherapy treatment I would have been
miserable